you've got a pack of cards I'll give you
a quick look through them you can see it
kind of just a random order there but
this trick is about shuffling anyway so
we're going to try and make them even
more of a random order and I'm not even
going to shuffle them you're going to
shuffle them what I'm going to ask you
to do in a second is deal out on to the
table as many as you like let's try and
make it roughly half so between 20 and
40 although it doesn't matter and then
you're going to riffle shuffle them
together this is me doing it for real
every where's your car seat they do do
like this like yeah just deal on the
table as made you like 27 at least seven
three eight play a guy here and I'll
just order them up decent nice and then
you're going to riffle shuffle those
together it's important to show you
Brady didn't do a perfect shuffle even
after all this practice you've been
having you've been telling me about so
I'm going to shuffle them in happy yep
in they go we're going to be weird if
after the random number of cards you
counted after the riffle shuffle you did
you actually shuffle them back into
order wouldn't it be strange it's just
not quite where I mean you've got to red
to black to me it doesn't look like you
actually have Brady does it no no not at
all except for unless and that's I could
maybe convince you that actually you did
shuffle into more them into order
because actually what you did without
realizing you shuffled it every two
cards every pair of cards has one of
each color the first two is a red in the
black next to red in the black red in
the black every two cards has one of
each color all the way through even if
there's points where there's a double
red together if we deal them off in twos
strangely each pair of two as one of
each color which surely you'd agree
that's quite improbable amazing but it
gets much more interesting than that
because wouldn't it be strange if every
four cards had one of each suit there's
a heart Club a spade a diamond they're
the next four cards as a heart clubs
played under even though they're in a
different order there's still definitely
one of each suit again a different order
every four cards two different order but
that's definitely
one of each suit in each foot isn't that
strange so maybe you are better at
shuffling then you thought it is quite
impressive but you know what Brady you
know we've done even better than that
you shuffled it every 13 cards has one
of each value 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 let's have a check of these 13 cards
it's definitely one of each value in H 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 Jack Queen Kings crazy
1 2 3 5 6 7 8 9 10 Jack Queen King oh
one of each order again isn't that
strain again one of each order and
you'll notice it's weird because the
order is different in each set of 13
fantastic would you would you like to
know some of the math behind in how you
can do it - oh you can sort out okay all
right let's do that
right I'm going to show you the
properties of a permutation that you go
through when you do that shuffle so the
shuffle being that you deal out a
certain number of cars and then you
riffle shuffle them in it doesn't matter
if it's not perfect what properties does
that permutation have so they
demonstrate it I've numbered the cards
just with the natural counting numbers 1
2 252 and we're going to do that shuffle
to these cars just to see what happens
the first thing was you dealt out some
cards again it doesn't matter how many
dealt out I think I think you did 28
yeah because you did you did a
surprisement again what's important here
is when you deal them out you reversing
the order that's the crucial thing so
because of the ones at the top now it's
going to be at the bottom 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
10 11 5 6 7 28 so there's your 28 cards
with the order reversed ok now we're
going to riffle these two together and
the only thing we can guarantee is that
this card is going to get shuffled in
above this card above this card and so
on and so on okay these are going to get
riffle together in a second when we push
these together we're going to get a new
string of numbers okay when we push
string of numbers and we're going to
look at the crucial properties that
always occur in this permutation so the
first thing I want to try and convince
you
is that when we push these together if
we take the first let's say ten cards or
eleven cards or twelve cards there will
be a set of consecutive numbers for
example let's say the first ones that I
this first I get this one from this pile
and this one maybe another one maybe the
one from this part maybe another one but
you can see what happens whenever I add
one to the bottom of the pile as I
shuffle them together the one I add it's
always going to be one smaller than the
smallest card I have so far or one
bigger than the biggest card I have so
far because here I'm kind of counting
down here I'm counting up so I'm either
going to be adding one smaller than the
smallest car they have so far or one
bigger than the biggest card that means
that the cars are collect here we'll all
be consecutive because I've just built
it built them up by taking one from one
side or the other side of this side this
side so it all be consecutive string of
numbers 26 27 28 29 30 so they are
consecutive even though they're mixed up
and they didn't matter how many I take
I'll still get a string of consecutive
numbers even though they're mixed up
okay that's a guaranteed fat
you
the next thing I want to convince you of
is that the first K numbers are all
different module okay so just in case we
don't know what modulo is modulo is
essentially the remainder you get when
you divide by that number so six and
modulo five is one that has a remainder
of one and eleven modulo five is also
one well 12 modulo 5 is 2 so they've got
to tap two fives two fives and then
we've got the two let's just look at
we'll look at fives for now so if we
look at the first five cards they're
consecutive numbers and not in the right
order
but these numbers are consecutive we
have five consecutive numbers it's
actually a guaranteed fact that they
will be all be different modulo five so
let me try and explain that like this
I've written out the first 16 counting
numbers and if I take the first 5 you
can see they're all different modulo 5
if I divide by 5 I get remainder 1 the
remainder 2 remainder 3 24 remainder 0
and if I shift it up to the next 5
consecutive numbers I've lost this
modulo 1 but I've gained this one here
so even though I've lost this module 1
I've gained this one so these 5
consecutive numbers are still all
different modulo 5 and I could do it
again each time I shift up I lose this
modulo 5 I've gained the equivalent
value at the top and you can keep on
doing that each time losing a value but
gaining the equivalent modulo value at
the top so that means any five numbers
will all be different modulo 5 and
actually any six numbers will all be
different modulo 6 for whatever value we
take and the third fat so here I've
taken out the first ten of our shuffle
now we know that these ten numbers are
all different modulo 10 if they're all
different modulo 10 then there must be
two of each value modulo 5 can you see
that here there's 2 modulo 2 that were
equivalent to 1 modulo 5 to equivalent
to 2 3 4 5 and so on so we've got 10
numbers all different modulo 10 but two
of each modulo 5 so these 5 are all
different modulo 5 and that means that
the next 5 are also going to be
different modulo 5 and actually if we
continue that on the next 5 would be
different modulo 5 and so on and so
we continue that indefinitely each set
of five has one of each value each
equivalent value modulo five that is all
you need to know about this trick
because in this trick we haven't
actually used numbers we've used the
values of cards because these numbers
starting counting although they
naturally cycle through the different
values for each modulo so for each set
of four we've got 1 modulo 4 2 3 0 1
modulo 4 2 3 0 and so on or we can look
at modulo 13 which would relate to the
different values and so on so to do this
trick we need to set up the cards they
cycle through the different values just
as the counting numbers cycles through
the different modulus ok so maybe I can
relate the clubs to 1 mod 4 maybe I can
relate the hearts to 2 mod for the
spades to 3 mod 4 diamonds to 0 mod 4 ok
so we know we're going to have it so it
goes clubs hearts spades diamonds clubs
hearts spades diamonds that also is
black red black red black red so kind of
alternating modulo 2 as well and because
we wanted to do this thing with values
of the cards the ACE through kings we
want a system that cycles through the
ACE through Kings in the repeating cycle
as well but just having a 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 Jack Queen King looks like it's an
ordered pack so what we do we have us we
have a stack system so it looks mixed up
but actually is a repeating order so the
very start when I showed Brady the cards
at first glance maybe it looked around
them but actually it was completely
ordered completely set I'm going to get
them so they cycle through clubs hearts
spades diamonds and also so they cycle
through one of each value every 13 cards
so here's a pack of cards we've got it
completely ordered so I'm going to use a
very famous way of stacking the cards
that uses a Reyn 8 Kings threaten to
save 9 fair ladies for one sick knave
I'll show you what I mean ok we're going
to get clubs hearts spades down and set
eight kings
threaten 3:10 to save 7 save 9 fair
ladies for one sick knave and then we
just do it again but now we're starting
at the heart we started originally at
the club now it has 8 Kings 3:10 to save
9 fair ladies for one
oops ladies sick knave I've got two more
8 Kings
1 sick knave see in not only cycles just
how the counting numbers cycle through
odds and evens so different values
modulo 2 this also cycles through black
red black red black red black red just
how the counting numbers cycles through
different values modulo 4 lab heart
space diamonds clubs hearts spades
diamonds Club heart space times by the
way then the modern in one egg magicians
usually use for that is chased see 4
clubs each four hearts
that's for speedy 4 diamonds and then
you can see just how the counting
numbers cycles through the different
values modulus 13 we cycle through the
different 13 possible values of a card
set 8 King 3 10 - 7 9 5 Queen for a 6
Jack then then you can just start the
trick but I you could have actually
added one more convinced that which I
might want to do you can say as a it's a
pack of cards all different cards and
you can let them give them a cut so you
can say to them I want to I want to let
you start the pack at any any card you
like so you can cut the pack anywhere it
cut about anywhere you like and then
they can start from that deal enough and
that'll be fine because it will still
cycle through the different values in
order and the different suits and order
and red black red black so you can start
with a cut if you like if you want to
even more convincing this numberphile
episode was supported by audible.com
leading provider of
audiobooks and spoken material audibles
got over a hundred and eighty thousand
titles to choose from and if this video
has got you in the mood for some magic
why not try Jonathan strange and Mr
Norrell by Susanna Clark it's a great
alternative history tale about magic
making a comeback to England in the 19th
century it's not just a great story but
a substantial novel with the audio book
weighing in at over 30 hours
perfect for wiling away all that time
during commutes to work long drives or
otherwise boring plane flights so why
not give it a try with audibles famed
30-day trial you can cancel anytime if
it's not via now you can download the
book I just suggested or any other of
your choice for free when you go to
audible.com slash numberphile audible is
great I use it myself as a paying
customer and I'd like to thank them
again for supporting this video